[Music]
three two one action it's cool you say
that the same way every time yeah it's
really every single time right its
pre-sleep Thanks
okay so when you guys go up to someone
that has recently had someone in their
lives poop on the calculate no it's
actually a lot darker than that it cuts
away oh joy dark poop oh yeah well they
ate their own toe no that's gross no one
in their lives have passed away well I
think she's gonna say pass some gas when
you go up to them what do you say oh no
it is my condolences I mean depending on
the relationship - really depends on the
person if they're if they have a good
sense of humor I try to like make like a
dark humor joke oh I know right but if
they're not congratulations y'all got to
be really sensitive to who it is I'm
talking to you for me when when someone
has just had someone passed away I feel
like that they've had so many people
saying the same thing already that I try
to I try to just glaze over it if
they're like if they're like yeah you
know like I like my aunt just passed or
something I feel like they've had so
many my condolences damn blah blah blah
she's finally down I'm like I was like I
like a hashset man that sucks and then I
move on like well like I try to change
the subject because I feel like they've
talked about it so actually I do the
same [ __ ] because if you most people
will be like oh I gotta see how they're
doing right and it's like [ __ ]
do you know how many times I had to
repeat this [ __ ] story
that's my Baba yeah that's exactly what
I had my dad pass away like and people
were coming up to me like I just saw it
as a sign of respect so I wasn't going
like oh not again it got talking about I
was just like damn they care that I'm
out I was like well thank you care that
much to like give me your time like that
just if someone passes away don't ask me
[ __ ] cuz I don't want to explain it 20
different times yeah sure I'll gate
sometimes people really want to talk
about it then sometimes they don't see
you got to read the
yeah yeah if they seem like they need
that support or they're just tired of
[ __ ] talking about the same [ __ ] over
and over I know somebody had somebody
pass away like a woman or some [ __ ] and
I see them I'm like I'm like we go
around in the same boat cuz I go yeah
like um um I care about you but the same
time I don't know how to do I almost
don't want to avoid that conversation
usually I'll full-on cross the street so
for me um sometimes I will say this
phrase which is a Latin phrase I'm sorry
for your loss
mmm sometimes that that will be my
response like when I find out someone
lost something and this blog post here
on Psychology Today com they're talking
about how people should just stop saying
I'm sorry for your loss because grief
cuz it doesn't even rhyme
there's one thing I know that does work
if someone passes away and you do a
freestyle of the PERT in the past the
weight they usually they're happy you
know if you're like hey hey ho ho I'm
sorry that your family member had to go
hey boss I'm sorry but your loss that's
why if someone passes away just got a
got a freestyle of a homie I'm sorry
you're gonna start feeling lonely yeah
[ __ ] yo what the [ __ ]
boss loves that see that's good that's
good that was more like sad yeah oh [ __ ]
all right I gotta work on it I'll go
back to the lab no more of an emo rapper
I think okay okay okay so what they're
saying here is that grief does not equal
loss so they're saying that ya when
someone passes it creates like it leads
into a valley where your life is forever
altered now that you have losses per or
not lost but now that this person has
gone and so they're saying that grief
robs us of the
innocent warmth that comes with knowing
where we are headed it leaves us exposed
vulnerable and desolate grief has a way
of creating a vacuum of air around us
that steals our ability to take a deep
breath so they're saying here that
people should be looking at grief in a
new way where so they're saying that a
lot of people try to convince others
that they can over overcome grief and
the last thing you want to do is lecture
a [ __ ] to I don't worry
that's nothing instead of saying sorry
for your loss say I hope your grief is
brief oh good grief is brief yeah well
there they also gave some suggestions
they're saying instead of that just say
like nothing will ever be the same
whoa that sounds water or my heart hurts
for you because yes because of this
there's no turning back now I'd like
that one the reason why they're saying
nothing will ever be the same is because
when you're using it as I'm sorry for
your loss it's creating a distance so
like a buffer that's hopefully I won't
experience the grief you're experiencing
that's what they're trying to get to I
don't hear that [ __ ] or if you can
change the emotion would be great too
it's like hey don't be sad that they're
dead demand that they're dead instead
yeah just be angry about it how about be
glad
don't be mad be glad it's all just kind
of like semantics though you know I'm
saying because it's like you deal with
death how're you gonna do with day like
for me like my dad's been talking about
justice I was a little kid you know I'm
saying so he's always been like look
it's a part of life that's like I'm
gonna go one day you know just like show
me you love me now I'm still here blah
blah he's like I don't don't even cry
when I'm dead she's like that so he's
like kind of like let me joke about
death all the time right so if someone
came up to me regardless of if they say
hey nothing's gonna be the same or sorry
for your loss
I'm gonna process it the same way cuz
I'm gonna deal with death the same way
regardless of what words they're using
you know I'm saying I mean what it's
always like that's the way the cookie
crumbles
it sound like it's more like maybe
workplace etiquette or the tightest with
cuz like in this room I don't think any
of us would say [ __ ] like that
sorry for your loss it would going to be
unspoken and you just hug now like
they're there probably no exchange of
words you know because we're like we're
close I don't know my head would have
been like so what do people normally say
the cookie crumbles hey [ __ ] happens me
casa su casa
Taco Bell Grande right not just well
Rhonda yeah oh yeah you're just talking
about how I guess this article is kind
of helpful for people who are currently
grieving I thought it yeah I kind of
like walks you through the way that you
can can deal with grief without telling
you how to do it yeah cuz most people
don't deal with grief the way I think we
do we just laugh about it eventually a
lot of people they they need to marinate
and sit on it for a while versus I think
a lot of us are able to kind of make fun
and that's maybe how we deal with some
sad situations the only way the way I
deal with grief is like I need to I have
to sit in it and I have to be like okay
let me just experience this and let me
feel it and like let it go through me
and then once it's out then I'm like
okay that's that's what I had I needed
to go through I do think my life will
never be the same because now there is
this like this thing that's like there's
a void like there's a void once that
person is gone cuz like in my heart like
you know I have spaces for everyone
that's there and like this person's gone
so there's a void and that's just
something that I now have to live with
and so to me that's kind of how you go
through it yeah that's also sad to you
that's very sad it's not like she's
marinating in it I think what she's
saying is she goes through it in the
appropriate time frame
and then like they're not forgotten it's
like they're still in her - Sergio she's
wrong what other thing the other thing I
think I think it's sad if if you see
that hole in your heart constantly but
because it's like if you if you you're
constantly thinking emptiness emptiness
void but if you if you like if you sit
in it and you processed it and you're
like I have this hole it's there and
that's how it is and like you know not
necessarily it's not like there's a
Swiss cheese that's the way I live with
it right it's almost like okay look it's
less of a hole and it's the impact that
person made on you right you know I'm
saying you don't have to forget about it
it's the thing you forget about a
[ __ ] Swiss cheese you know but it's
just like something like the better way
to put it yeah holds an impact yeah it's
a it's a dent that someone made I relate
to that because when again when I lost
my dad like it's a it's it's the impact
or the void or whatever but I'm not like
like it's it's still painful when I
think about it but it's not something
that's stopping me in my tracks and I'm
like feeling it all over again it's just
like oh I miss him yeah when my grandpa
died I was doing stink about it all day
you're what doing stick about it all day
oh just like bits at the gas station and
the guys like you know that'll be 350 do
you know Mike great yeah my grandpa's
done that's how I do it's almost like
the more times I'm able to laugh at it
the faster I can heal but I can't laugh
at or if I can't make fun of it then it
becomes like this wound that's not
yielding yeah I was like I was like 11
or something Mike my uncle died and so
and I now there's in writers rooms years
later and any times people did bits
about AIDS cuz like you know writers
from people I was beating the [ __ ] heads
and stuff I'd be like my uncle died of
AIDS
did he really yeah oh [ __ ] where's they
always the bit
no but that's that's the bit is that it
freezes the room a bit making people
uncomfortable eases
everyone's like oh they like wait really
and like really I don't yeah
and I'm like it he was a gay man he died
of AIDS and he was yeah that is he did
that means yes so it's just fun this is
the way that I process are any yet
things weird cuz like I don't like cans
brother during his dad's funeral right
it was his dad's time to go up to his
dad passed away no no his dad's like his
dad mom's funeral
Oh is his grandma his grandma right so
during the funeral his dad it was his
turn to go up to to the viewing right
and for some odd reason during that
moment when cans dad was saying goodbye
to his mother Ted's mother thought it
would be a great perfect time to pass
his grandma's up there he goes up he
[ __ ] pants his dad and he's crying
with his pants around his [ __ ] ankle
we didn't stop crying and he slowly puts
his [ __ ] pants back up and his mom
laughing stupid the brother is the
brother hold the pants down he's like
I'm grieving the brother you could you
go to another family members funeral or
something you go to a funeral that the
brothers part of you you start walking
up a bunch of people have their pants
like down as you walk in like it's his
December hit it's something he's
definitely haha because then they could
wear like a belt but they're like no no
the way what see well my boy
his uncle passed away right and he was
like and he wanted to bring his uncle's
favorite beer to like like to maybe like
pour on the casket or like or something
but he wasn't sure if it was gonna be
like disrespectful or not because I was
you know cuz he you're pointing on the
casket and he said he pulled up to the
funeral and the and the casket was like
drenched in beer everybody brought his
favorite beer and was like pouring it on
the cash he's uncle alcoholic yeah he
died of how close if not a house another
his favorite beer yeah
[Music]